dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir this piece of
work is an amazing application of deep
neural networks that performs semantic
scene completion from only one depth
image this depth image is the colorful
image that you see here where the colors
denote how far away different objects
are from our camera we can create these
images inexpensively with commodity
hardware for instance Microsoft Kinect
has a depth sensor that is suitable for
this task the scene completion part
means that from this highly incomplete
depth information the algorithm
reconstructs the geometry for the
entirety of the room even parts that are
completely missing from our images or
things that are occluded the output is
what computer graphics researchers like
to call a volumetric representation or a
voxel array which is essentially a large
collection of tiny LEGO pieces that
build up the scene but this is not all
because the semantic part means that the
algorithm actually understands what we
are looking at and thus is able to
classify different parts of the scene
these classes include walls windows
floors sofas and other furniture
previous works were able to do scene
completion and geometry classification
but the coolest part of this algorithm
is that it not only does these steps way
better but it does them both at the very
same time this work uses a 3d
convolutional neural network to
accomplish this task the 3d part is
required for this learning algorithm to
be able to operate on this kind of
volumetric data as you can see the
results are excellent and are remarkably
close to the ground truth data if you
remember not so long ago I flipped out
when I've seen the first neural network
based techniques that understood 3d
geometry from 2d images that technique
used a much more complicated
architecture a generative adversarial
Network which also didn't do scene
completion and on top of that the
resolution of the output was way lower
which intuitively means that the LEGO
pieces were much larger this is insanity
the rate of progress in machine learning
research is just stunning
probably even for you seasoned fellow
scholars who watch two minute papers and
have high expectations we've had plenty
of previous episodes about the inner
workings of different kinds of neural
networks I've put some links to them in
the video description make sure to have
a look if you wish to brush up on your
machine learning calc for a bit the
authors also published a new data set to
solve these kind of problems in future
research works and it is also super
useful because the output of their
technique can be compared to ground
truth data when new solutions pop up in
the future this data set can be used as
a yardstick to compare results with the
source code for this project is also
available tinkerers rejoice thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
[Music]